- I don't know the difference
between a rifle and a shotgun.
- A shotgun is a...
- I know it's like that.
- I feel like they're, like, too lenient.
- I know that they are not as strong
as I would like them to be.
- Well I grew up in
Buffalo, in New York State.
I didn't have a gun in my house,
I didn't really know anyone who had a gun.
- We forget that there's the
rest of the entire state.
- I feel like we're
gonna have answers that,
what you hope it is, and then
- [Woman] Right
- what it actually is.
- It might be true.
You can buy a gun at 18 in New York.
- True.
- [Both] Oh.
- [Man] Alright.
- Okay.
- Tony won.
- Now York, I have a
good feeling about you.
- Good job. Okay.
- The age laws are kind of arbitrary
and I wish there was some
sort of maturity test.
- That was a good trick question though.
- I'm going purely based
off of, like, video games.
- What is a permit?
Is that just like getting a license?
- Yeah, sort of like a
marriage license, right?
- I'm starting to feel like it's maybe,
there's a lot of laws
in the state, alright.
Yeah. All of the above.
- C,
- [Both] Shotgun.
- I think I'm going with handgun.
- Handgun okay.
- Going small.
- The rifle and shotgun, you can just
walk into a Walmart and buy it.
- That is insane!
- [Man] Gonna walk around
a little easy now.
- That's different than a permit?
- Oh.
- You register your gun when,
just to let, I would
say, the government know
that you own the gun.
And a permit is, like, a
license to drive a gun?
- I'm gonna say that is
True.
- Dude, you needed a permit to purchase
a handgun in New York State,
then you would be registering your handgun
in the state of New York.
So this is False
- [Woman] True.
- You do need to register
- [Woman] Wait, oh yeah
- a handgun.
- [Woman] You do need.
- I was trying to, I feel
like the gun laws are so crazy
that sometimes you never know.
- I love the phrase
"burglar's instruments"
- B: Unlawful entry into a building.
- I'm gonna say A.
- None of the above.
- Yeah. I'm gonna say D as well.
- Amazing.
- Good job.
- Just knowing how difficult it is
to acquire a gun in New York,
it actually makes me feel safer.
- Overall, they're good laws,
but obviously there are
some cracks somewhere,
because too many people have guns.
- If someone from another
part of the state came into
an area in the state
that had different laws,
that's really difficult
to arbitrate in court.
- The gun laws in New York City,
I mean, it's just such a
large population of people
in such a condensed area.
It's good to know that
there's heavy restriction.
- Good job New York.